-
Monday PFT ot also part of the PFT p.m.
podcast feed Cristen Mike Florio stuff
we didn't get to or feel like talking
about a little bit more after making
ourselves a little bit loopy talking
about the NFL for two hours three for me
on the sixth Monday of the regular
season
let's go back to the Cowboys yeah
because they were three you know and we
had some video of Jerry Jones in the
locker room and I saw a tweet from
Calvin Watkins at the Dallas Morning
News that Jerry Jones was was shaken
yesterday it was a seventy seventh
birthday this Cowboys team was supposed
to be special they had anything lined up
they paid his EQ Elliott to get him into
the fold we I remember talking after
three weeks they have any weaknesses
other than coaching no but then you know
the coaching is now starting to rear its
ugly head I think they're relying too
much on the talent of the team there's
enough scheming there's enough game
planning there's enough creativity and
now we have to wonder Jason Garrett
who's only under contract through this
year yeah is he in a situation where a
disastrous loss to the Eagles for
example right Sunday Night Football
could that be the thing that causes
Jerry Jones to roll out of bed the next
day and say I gotta make a change I
don't think so yeah you know again know
where they're in trouble if they lose
this weekend is I think they're like
forget the wild card none of that's
gonna happen
but they're still very much in the race
to win the NFC East and I think you stay
the course 100% you know but here's the
thing yeah if they lose to the Eagles at
home right they have to play in
Philadelphia later this yeah I know you
get swept yeah you've got to make up
three games right elsewhere I know and
that's not gonna be easy to know it's
not easy but they they went into
Philadelphia last year on Sunday Night
Football and beat them right we can't
forget about that you know there they
are kind of one of those teams when you
think they're not gonna their backs are
against the wall they somehow you know
pulled through it they have incredible
talent you know you can live with the
Saints loss a few weeks ago okay
the Packers lost last week even though
it's not easy to live with hey mistakes
happen dak Prescott interceptions early
they
get behind not a good look certainly but
then you know this game yesterday I
think is where the concern level rises a
little bit because we know they are far
superior than the New York Jets and the
New York Jets have been unable to really
do anything I think I was just surprised
that the offense couldn't punch in the
ball four touchdowns having to settle
for field goals not sustaining drives or
finding big plays in the run game or the
pass game really throughout the day and
then the defense letting up some of the
big plays you know early on I think that
was another thing I just did not expect
I thought the Cowboys would kind of
overwhelm that Jets offense in general
and yeah they would win a game by 10 or
14 points something like that but the
Jets had other plans and they had a good
game playing off the bye week and Sammy
Darnell gave him the lift yeah it was
last year they were three and five going
into a Sunday night game at the Eagles
and and at the time right there was a
thought that if they got embarrassed it
could be that's it for Jason Garrett and
that vibe has begun to creep back in
even though they're only three and three
the bar was so much higher this year and
you get off to that three or no start
last year they started one and two that
creates expectations that begins to
develop the sense that it's going to be
a special season and they've seen the
special season come crashing down and
like you said now it I think they're
already at the point where based upon
how this team has played the past few
weeks it's NFC East championship or
you're not going to the playoffs and
look what what they are able to do by
way of holding serve at home on Sunday
night against the Eagles gonna go a long
way toward determining whether they win
that division and I don't have we've
been so bad at picking these Sunday
night games this year I think I'm gonna
I think I'm going to make my decision
and then literally do the opposite yeah
yeah I know it's you know you get
conventional wisdom would would make you
think Oh Dallas is at home you know
backs against the wall they should be
able to win this game the problem is you
know the Eagles are talented too now
they're beat up that's their biggest
issue but the Eagles are certainly not
gonna be intimidated by the Dallas
Cowboys the Eagles you know got a lot of
big people up front on both sides of the
ball they're not gonna lose that matchup
in any you know bad way or anything like
that you know the thing I look at you
know more than anything I'm a little
disappointed
Ezekiel who's been good I'm not trying
to say he's not good
then keys doesn't look quite as
explosive to me so that's concerning to
me you know the the past offense I think
has been very good it's encouraging is
as good as we've seen you know since
Tony Ramon is prime the defense I do
have like my concerns there I know
there's talent DeMarcus Lawrence hasn't
been as good but the big thing there and
going into the coaching thing is I do
think their defense has to be a little
bit more game plan specific you know
they are one of those teams and I know
you've heard me say this lots and lots
that they just go out there you know
what the Cowboys are gonna play and do
they don't like really do anything
special on a week-to-week basis they
just go this is what we do we're really
talented our power our speed is just
gonna overwhelm you we're gonna hustle
we're gonna tackle and do all that okay
great but you know this is the NFL they
even when you are a really talented team
like the Dallas Cowboys you're not like
so much more greatly talented than maybe
one of the worst teams in football in
the New York Jets to where you can just
roll out there and go we're just gonna
be us and beat them no I mean the New
England Patriots game planned and did a
lot of different stuff when they play in
the New York Jets they and just go
word--not England and we're home and
we're gonna beat them
no they treated it like damn they got
some good things you know you hear Bill
Belichick the Jets are really good at
all three areas a really good little
ball team and they never fall into that
trap they always go we gotta find ways
to help our players and I don't know we
see that especially in the Cowboys d
yeah it's just we're supremely talented
a team and we're just gonna show up and
we're gonna do what we do and right and
I think they need to have more
creativity and it makes me wonder
whether or not if they continue to lose
these games you know Jason Garrett
status beyond this season is seriously
in doubt right now but whether or not at
some point Jerry Jones will decide to
give Chris Rashard an opportunity to be
the interim coach just to audition once
you know that's the thing once you know
you're making the change yeah that's
when you want to give somebody else a
chance to show what they can do can they
win some games under pressure because
that's a sinker and Wade Phillips know
years ago I got it Wade Phillips was
gone and Jason Garrett got a chance to
prove that he's the guy and and I can't
help but wonder whether or not Chris
Rashard is gonna be the new Jason
Garrett but it's something to keep an
eye on especially as these losses
continue to pile up the Chiefs have
a couple of losses pile up at home
that's really a stunner it looked like
they were ready to continue to go
unbeaten for as many weeks as they
possibly could leading up to that
December eighth showdown against the
Patriots but losses at the Colts and the
Texans can they turn it around and when
you look at their schedule you've got
some tough games this year right I do
think they can turn it around I mean I
still think they're extremely dangerous
you know the old phrase especially for
me follow the money okay and they got
some money that's just not there right
now you know Tyree killed just got back
in the lineup you saw you know what he
can do for them as a football team yeah
they're missing their you know was Eric
what was Fischer the first pick of the
draft second pick in the draft was 23rd
right there missing him at left tackle
okay Chris Jones didn't play yes
Watkins Sammy Watkins of course who's
being paid money like he's one of the
five or six best receivers in football
better deal than Obie Trice so you know
that those are big big big people to
miss for that football team their
defense is never gonna be special this
year they are about out scoring people
where I am concerned is I don't know if
they might have to address
Adrina adjust their defensive formula
you know and I don't know if you heard
what I said when we were doing the show
you know it's either maybe hey we gotta
just start blitzing and pressure in and
do crazy stuff to maybe create turnovers
or they score so our offens can get on
the field or change something you're
doing up front right now it's just too
easy to run the football and keep my
homes in the offense on the sideline and
that's that's my biggest concern with
them right now I kind of like that idea
like we know we have confidence in our
offense so let's just go out make it a
shooter have it right and either give
them a touchdown or we're gonna get the
ball back but they're not gonna have
these nine minute drive I think they
wear our defense down and they keep our
offense for us exactly I think that's
something they have to maybe toss around
that idea of just like let's try to make
some more plays on the defensive side of
the ball so what if we give up a 50-yard
touchdown once a game or here and there
whatever it may be you got Patrick
mahomes and of course one of the most
explosive offenses we've ever seen and
they're really the thing you said is
hurting them right now is he's over
there drinking Gatorade more than he's
playing football
consider this ya got the short week at
Denver yeah and last year remember they
were down
points to the bride a Monday night game
that was when the legend of mahomes was
beginning left throw right and brought
him back and then won that game right
but at Denver is not gonna be easy the
Broncos have some life and they've yet
to win a home game this year they're
gonna want this one badly yeah then
they've got oh you're in wrong it's
Sunday Night Football week eight Aaron
Rodgers coming to town and then the
following week the Vikings can run the
ball down your throats I mean that would
be the perfect team to throw the kitchen
sink if they don't adapt to that before
week nine week nine is the ideal go
after them take chances try to rattle
Kirk Cousins and if he finds Stefon
Diggs wide open so be it we get the ball
back and we'll try to match them score
yeah four score and at Tennessee we know
how the Titans are definitely Titans are
dangerous especially when you write them
off right at the chart and they got no
England and Patricia I mean New England
and Dean peas and for Abel you know
they're gonna have a tack to slow down
that Kansas City Pass game maybe yeah I
mean they still have to go to New
England yeah they have to go to Chicago
oh they do have the Chargers twice and
the Chargers don't look good right now
but three and two yeah that was a great
day for the Raiders to not be playing
and to have both the Chargers and the
Chiefs lose right it really is it really
was and then let's not forget to like
the Chiefs didn't just steamroll the
Raiders in Oakland you know a few years
back yeah they scored 28 points in the
second quarter but the other three
quarters they had issues moving the ball
a little bit and you know even Oakland
move the ball on them a little bit that
day and I know they didn't convert on
some third downs I think Derek Carr had
a bad interception but either way you
know I'm not like panicked about the
Kansas City Chiefs but they do have to
adjust some things and they gotta get
they gotta get healthy for and to feels
bad for the chief it does write four and
two feels great for the Panthers yeah
because they lost two games four days
apart to start the season they lost to
the Rams they lost to the Buccaneers
what the hell's wrong with Cam Newton oh
we know what's wrong he's got a mid-foot
sprain that he had hidden from the team
and they acted like they didn't know
what was going on since then Kyle Allen
four starts four wins we saw the great
win in you sound like deaf online then
yes I like it and I don't even know what
that reference is I just I'm used to you
saying no it's we're getting so
I don't I don't I didn't see it or oh
you need to see that movie is very funny
so anyway uh was it okay yeah
Carolina pants it's gonna be healthy
right right
what do you do and it's funny because
you've already got people who are like
oh well you're not saying the same thing
about Drew Brees well Drew Brees is the
all-time passing yardage leader when
he's healthy he's back playing again
Kyle Allen is the future Cam Newton is
the we don't know what right now for the
Carolina Panthers yes he was the MVP
four years ago but he's either injured
or we're worried about the next injury
with Cam Newton it never stops and this
is a way for them to break that cycle
and just go with a guy who can run the
offense who you don't have this constant
fear that we're doing too much or are we
not doing enough are we holding them
back are we putting them at risk and I
think it's a liberating feeling for the
Panthers to not have that that constant
criteria right of Cam Newton's proper
use hovering over the head or a tiny
practice and be healthy and all those
things so yeah and I I don't I mean it's
I think it's a pretty serious injury I
really do
right and if you're the Panthers you
kind of want to let this right now III
hear you you know I will stand by what
I've been saying I still think the
Carolina Panthers will be at their best
with a healthy Cam Newton but right now
Kyle Allen's gonna make it hard on them
to make that move right away until like
Cam Newton's a hundred and ten percent
and you know yes I mean he's for no as a
starter now they got a bye week you know
no I don't want to throw Cam Newton out
there in the next game they got a play
at San Francisco 49ers and that group
you know maybe you know maybe that's the
game where okay we put Kyle on there one
more time we see if he is for real and
maybe that's the game you start to draw
the line on you know oh gosh you know we
were kind of steamrolled by that that
49ers defense maybe that'll show them
yeah I think that'll be a huge point for
them it's either gonna show them man
Kyle Allen's surreal and we got to ride
this out because we beat the San
Francisco 49ers or even if they lost
close I think you still have to ride
with them but if they like feel like we
got overwhelmed and Kyle Allen was
overwhelmed by their team a little bit
maybe that finally does give them the
confidence to go back to Cam Newton I
think as I've said before
that when camp noon is healthy and
you're ready to go back to them when
this Kyle I'm think cools off if and
when it cools off you can go back to Cam
Newton and you can just do Cam Newton
things not worry about him getting
injured because if he gets injured yeah
you've got another guy right fine there
yeah here's the other thing too here's
the other reason why I think there's a
presumption that we're going to see Drew
Brees and a question about whether we're
gonna see Cam Newton we see Drew Brees
every game right we see Drew Brees doing
the thumb flexes getting ready to go and
he's there and he's helping Teddy
Bridgewater yeah Cam Newton's been out
of sight out of mind
yeah and and the team says well you know
we don't want him to be standing on that
foot well they have benches yeah he
could be on the bench he could have the
tablet he could be helping Kyle Allen
and he's just not around and I think
that's part of the out of sight out of
mind
off we go and you know Cam Newton's got
one year left after this season on his
contract and I always thought this was
an upper out year for Cam Newton anyways
yeah yeah Danner he's gonna be gone
right right now it feels like he's gonna
be gone yeah you have to ask at some
level just he want to be there is he
thinking at this stage of my career
maybe my best play is to go somewhere
else I don't know where he'd want to go
right but maybe my best play is to go
somewhere else yeah you know maybe he
certainly has made his mark on the city
he's still a phenomenal phenomenal
football player and hey there are teams
that don't don't let injured players be
around and do that stuff like New
England you're not gonna see any injured
players in the sidelines during that you
know I don't know what Cam Newton's
reason is I don't know if I necessarily
believe what they're saying either way I
think it's smart it by Cam Newton North
Carolina who's out there it can be a
distraction with him there I mean gosh
let's just talk about the guys that are
there that are playing football I think
the last three weeks we would have
watched these games Carolina's playing
and there would have been like 10
minutes devoted to Cam Newton sitting on
the sidelines you know and what are they
gonna do in Camden and then you know you
don't have to hear that or the Carolina
Panthers don't have to deal with it so I
understand them kind of keeping him out
of the spotlight when this goes on but
Kyle Allen again not doing things where
I go oh wow this is so amazing just
really playing the position pure he's
just taken what's there to be had every
now and then he'll make a throw where
you go that was pretty good throw good
for Kyle Allen and
they can run the ball and they got a
defense and you know this is why we
thought they would be in the NFC
playoffs right I mean we knew this team
was good they really blew two early
season games because of Cam Newton and
his health status and you know now
they're gonna be in a fight to make the
playoffs I've got two teams I'm
intrigued by that I'm thinking about I'm
projecting into the future seeing Cam
Newton yeah right now yeah I want to
hear the Chargers okay
that's a good one Chargers yeah you
trying to get entertained on new stadium
right Cam Newton man you know it just
feels like this Phillip Rivers thing
he's gonna be one of the aging
quarterbacks maybe the only one who
doesn't get to leave on his own terms
yeah he's done after this year based on
what we've seen so far this season and
also hey 10 Bay Buccaneers put them in
Bruce Arians if they don't keep Jameis
Winston and you don't want me Carolina
I'll show you Carolina I've got the
Brett Favre over that river Gerald McCoy
I'm gonna stay in the division and I'm
gonna stick it to you every chance I
know that's interesting thought
certainly I mean that is a very
interesting thought really I haven't
thought about this at all I'm just
trying to look at it there's any other
teams that jump out to me nobody else in
the NFC I don't see but I like where
you're at there and then you know
there's gonna be teams like the
Cincinnati Bengals that I think it'll be
going I'm gonna want to play for them I
wouldn't think so I'll draft somebody
you know that's just to force them to
come to you yeah right Tennessee Titans
they go where do they got sexy enough
yeah maybe not either I hear yeah I mean
it's not happening Cleveland Indy
Oakland yeah so I mean though I think
you might have hit the team's really on
the head there there it could be a
possibility last topic real quickly Tom
Brady was on WEEI today there's been a
narrative and I think it's the truth
yeah that if Tom Brady makes a personal
plea to Rob Gronkowski Gronkowski is
more likely to return what Tom Brady
said today is I love that guy I'm so
happy he's enjoying his time I'm happy
he's enjoying his life he seems to be
really doing a lot of things and I'm
having trouble scrolling here at his
great things he knows how I feel about
him I want what's best for him he's the
only person that can make those
decisions
I don't lobby for those things so loyal
I
so if Goss is gonna come back and and I
can understand where Brady's coming from
because if you lobby for the guy to come
back he comes back and he gets a serious
injury no yeah like it's on you exactly
what he's got to decide what he wants to
do and and maybe maybe he doesn't have
to
say it maybe their relationship is such
that Groff knows that Tom needs the help
he needs somebody we talked about this
Friday he needs somebody who can draw
extra attention so the rest of the
offense ofer up he had it with Antonio
Brown until he didn't you know he had it
for Rob Gronkowski for years and he
could get it back with Grande yeah no
there's the same degree that Gronk's a
guy who was five years ago we you just
have to blanket it right but still it
gives you a better element in it and it
does make your offense more well-rounded
no doubt about it they're missing the
tight end aspect of their offense in
general from what we've seen from the
Patriots over the last decade or so so
that is one element that they certainly
can improve but yeah I mean hey Brady
this is where Brady's you know yeah he's
a stand-up guy he just he he's not gonna
push this it is this is a personal
decision you know I think up until I saw
him do this deal with Fox I would have
thought there was a good chance but now
that Gronk has jumped into you know Fox
and Thursday Night Football and doing
some things it's at least lessen the
chance for me that along with again just
watching him on Thursday night looks
like he lost five more lost five more
pounds compared to the last time I saw
him on TV so that's where I worry about
it like if he's gonna make this decision
to come back and play he's gonna have to
make it at some palamoun Halloween yeah
it's got to come soon because he's gonna
have to work on getting his body back
into football shape get a little muscle
gonna bet a little size back on him
because he's certainly not physically
ready to do it right now he has to
emerge from the reserved retired list by
the Tuesday after week thirteen but at
some point before that he's got to be
packing on the pounds right and you're
right he's looking skinnier and skinnier
all the time anybody I mean he's Gronk
you know he's always gonna be that Gronk
kind of guy he was more polished than I
thought he was gonna be yeah but the
bars low for me cuz it's just kind of
like the big happy guy he's funny and in
quirky right but I think being around
football because he took a job in
football I think that's gonna make it
more likely yeah that's I thought the
only way that he was going to know under
no circumstances to come back is if he
got some sort of a movie role that he
was committed and he signed the contract
and he's there for 13 weeks and he can't
leave yes right when are they making
terminator yeah be back we'll be back
thanks for some of your time we've got
new unbuttoned today the day the
two-game deep dive it's not even up to a
boat boy they can't vote for that go off
the record don't want that word right in
Washington Miami I wanted to have to
watch that game check him out though
later today we'll be back tomorrow with
another pft live and around-the-clock
pro football talk calm everybody have a
great day see ya
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports